tiene un hornadito lolito ofrece El
plato típico de la Sierra ecuatoriana el
ser donado presente en cada mercado
popular andino guión Gómez es su
comensal líder de un grupo de chef
franceses que recorrieron el país
Buscando los Sabores tradicionales de
Ecuador una tentación muy difícil de
rechazar
poder entender la gastronomía ecuatorial
No la que nos cuentan No la que podemos
conocer a través de informes sino aquí
sobre el terreno y conocer los que hacen
esta gastronomía
ecuatoriano un chef que defiende la
identidad nacional culinaria desde este
mercado popular los aromas y colores se
convierten en una clase magistral para
Los visitantes Galos Bueno si tú no
sabes de tu origen y de tu identidad de
Qué cultura estamos hablando y la
cultura gastronómica de nuestro país y
la cultura gastronómica ecuatoriana es
abundante y muy rica la búsqueda la
respiración culinaria de la delegación
francesa en Ecuador también abordó los
Sabores amazónicos Juan José un jefe de
la gastronomía indígena prepara la Jean
Paco un envuelto de pollo de hojas en la
selva con el que intenta que sus padres
franceses conozcan El plato icónico de
la tradición ancestral en la selva
amazónica que tenemos tenemos
museos vivos
De tal suerte que esta cultura de
nuestros pueblos originarios debe ser
mostrada al mundo con respeto
el cacao es otro referente histórico de
la crítica culinaria ecuatoriana
principal fuente para la elaboración del
chocolate de romandino un viaje de
sabores que traslada Victoria experto en
chocolate franceses a su degustación por
Sudamérica estamos muy atractivos sobre
la trazabilidad la cualidad a los
productores a la manera de vivir con
Esta visita de Los Galos Ecuador se ha
impuesto varias metas con Francia entre
ellas ser un referente gastronómico
promover la exportación de chef
Ecuatorianos hacia el viejo continente
también planea convertirse en el
principal proveedor de productos
orgánicos en las cocinas francesas y
atraer el turismo galo a tierras andinas